[Musik]
es geschieht an einem dienstag um 12 45
in einem aussenquartier von zürich
ahmeti ist er seinem vater unterwegs
plötzlich taucht ein anderer
jugendlicher auf es kommt zu
gegenseitigen pöbeleien dann eskaliert
die situation dass er dem verblutung
stewart oder einer querschnittslähmung
entgangen ist war laut dem
rechtsmedizinischen institut zürich
reiner zufall
zwei jahre später sieht er denjenigen
der ihn fast umgebracht hätte im
fernsehen leader carlos ist mittlerweile
in einem sogenannten sonders setting
bestehend aus teil box unterricht einer
vier-zimmer-wohnung und privatlehrer für
29.000 franken pro monat
der fall carlos erhitzt seit tagen die
gemüter bis hin zum siedepunkt
fassungslosigkeit vor allem auch über
den der diese sonder setting angeordnet
hat jugendanwalt hans uli wibbe dankte
glos für die nach ihm darüber gesprochen
hätte dann hätte sie ist immer noch
kritik von das rating zu tun
ja ich habe da bin ich jetzt ein
spezialfutter auf bin ich zwei unter par
ein crashtest fragen mindestens und
wieder zurück war das ja dass er so
thaiboxer kanada seine straße ist doch
normal
[Musik]
ein jahr lang hat hans uhr liga über
geschieden und freiwillig seine
vorgesetzten hatten ihm einen maulkorb
verpasst gegenüber doch hinter nun
erstmals stellung er über falsches
jorisch vergangen sind
der film ist ein sieg laufen nicht wie
gut sie erhebt ich habe mir ganz gut ich
bin jetzt funktioniert aber stets auch
40 jahre für die ist auch wo ich so
schnell so interessiert natürlich
vorgeschrieben ist mit dem golf das war
nicht einfach
inzwischen mussten alle resozialisierung
bemühungen abgebrochen und carlos auf
einen fuß gesetzt werden
obwohl laut dem zürcher jugendgericht
eigentlich enge begleitung bräuchte
selbst körpers schärfste kritiker sagen
heute sonder sättigen jahr aber nicht zu
vor allem nicht zu teuer für bürger noch
heute ein nebenschauplatz einzige
unterwegs sie was muss ich mache das 3 d
league macht klar ist dass man die höhe
stemmen zurückfahren aber zum start der
heimat gefunden da machen wir jetzt
einfach alles was man sind damit nun
aber es passiert also startet das ist
schöpferische offen oder filme auch der
organist ja also das ist jetzt wie ihm
das ist für mich startphase bis jetzt
hat die umstrittene maßnahme einen
rückfall und damit weitere opfer
verhindert hauptziel erreicht findet
aber trotzdem war der skandal perfekt
pflegen wir hierzulande die
kuscheljustiz naiv und wirkungslos
braucht es tatsächlich mehr härte und
strengere gesetze der jugendstrafvollzug
in der schweiz sei zu teuer zu milde
manchmal brauche es statt kuscheljustiz
einfach die ganz harte tour
hier gibt es die ganz harte tour vom
ersten tag an sogenannte bootcamp sollen
verbrecher mit militärischen mitteln
wieder auf den rechten weg bringen
jugendliche und erwachsene männer und
frauen aufgeteilt in sogenannte kompanie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
die hatten keine gesunden
familienstrukturen
hier bringen wir struktur und
disziplinen ihr leben und sind
vaterfiguren für sie all das was sie nie
hatten die alltag besteht aus harter
körperlicher arbeit und dauert genau 90
tage es gibt keine einfühlsamen
gespräche auf augenhöhe und keine sonder
settings hier gibt es nur fast 70
prozent der schweizer möchten laut einer
repräsentativen umfrage ebensolche
bootcamps auch für renitente schweizer
jugendliche
[Musik]
marcel niggli präsidierte bis vor kurzem
die gesellschaft der deutschsprachigen
theologen erst dekan der juristischen
fakultät der uni fribourg wo auch lehrt
und forscht mit lee gilt als unbequemer
denker der sich traut auch unpopuläre
tatsachen auszusprechen bootcamps halte
ich für so eine glitschige lösung auch
mal was das dass die macher tab ist aber
dass das ein längerfristig stabil ein
effekt würde aufgrund von der
empirischen also erheblich spitz wie wir
also dass sich kurzfristig könnte
erreicht dass ein mensch nur quasi
einfach wie sie rüstet sondern
zurückhaltend und diszipliniert sich
bewegt das bedeutet nicht dass das nicht
innerhalb kürzester zeit wieder
verrottet weil die gewohnheit denn
einfach maßgeblicher sind und die
anderen sind nicht so schnell
nachhaltige resultate bringe der schutz
und die erziehung von jugendlichen ist
der schweizer gesetzgeber überzeugt
[Musik]
institutionen wie das jugendheim brill
soll nicht wegsperren und strafen
sie sollen erzielen indem sie der
entwicklung der persönlichkeit der
jugendlichen besondere beachtung
schenken
also nicht alle über einen leisten
schlagen sondern den einzelfall
möglichst genaue erfassen
[Musik]
für gott bedeutet dass unterbringung in
der sogenannten gwg der geschlossenen
wohngruppe also im
hochsicherheitsbereich nun schon seit
sechs monaten
denn beim 17-jährigen besteht akute
fluchtgefahr
der pilot wurde kriegs wert hat wieso
dann nach ausgang der sind auch kathi
lied wo da sind und die sind ja
eigentlich der wo3 setzte sich mit jedem
problem aussprache und sie dankt 90 1
anders lösen
zitat hat sie wissen alles besser was
sind leider passiert ist geheim und her
das minus an ge ist hier in einer so
genannten jugend maßnahme
diese enden mit spätestens 22 bis dahin
ist die dauer aber offen
das heißt geht bleibt so lange in prill
bis die jugendanwaltschaft findet dass
die maßnahme ziele erreicht seien
da
schlachtruf tracht
ja ist das gerät zuvor ist nicht einfach
da drin
schon vor der ersten zigarette geht es
hier los mit der kritik leben mühsam
findet die schöne ja meine dass man muss
sich das einfach vorstellen eine
gefangen ist ich hatte einen ganz
bestimmten zeitraum
er weiß genau am tag ich bin ich wieder
das innerhalb von der maßnahme
stellen sie innere da unten
auseinandersetzung jedes verhalten oder
handarbeit wird analysiert bewertet das
ist schlecht
da muss also sich recht anstrengend als
10 g/t league wird seit er zwölf jahre
alt ist er ist gewalttätig er klaut er
bricht ein
er gilt mit drogen nimmt drogen kurz
gesagt er ist ein intensivtäter
wieso sind sie so kräftig ausbauen grund
falsche kollege volker - ich will alles
ort kämpfen
auch trainerin sozialwohnungen sind
selbst in ihren büchern machen so sagt
ja wie macht sich dann bemerkbar
innerlich wortmann dass alles gut läuft
aber machen das anders
die justiz soll die perspektiven
jenseits der kriminalität aufzeigen
eine schwierige aufgabe ge ist 17 jahre
alt aber schulisch auf dem stand eines
drittklässler der kann kaum lesen und
schreiben
[Musik]
röseler mutter die direktorin des
jugendheims pal zeigt wo seit einem
halben jahr daran gearbeitet wird dass
ein neustart trotz allem realität werden
könnte entweder geschlossenen wohngruppe
sich jeweils la pampa vor augen abspielt
ausrufen hat somit tätige spiele was
ihre familie das billard südlichste
punkt ist und bibliothek bücher
das ist es wohl ziemlich vor der gruppe
780 franken kostet ein tag in velen im
monat also fast 25000 franken wobei ist
noch teurer geht gebe auch schon in der
psychiatrie
dort kostet ein monat über 40000 franken
wieso ist das so personalintensiv ist 4
20 stunden pro tag betreut
sozialpädagoge der tagesstruktur also
ausbildung beschäftigung atelier wurde
zurück auf die gruppe sie und man
endlich wieder ganz sicher jetzt also
sicherheitsdispositiv und die ganze
infrastruktur allein in den vergangenen
sechs monaten hat geht den staat fast
150000 franken gekostet
und das ist nur die spitze des eisberges
er ist seit fünf jahren in verschiedenen
institutionen untergebracht
ende offen als sie sich das schon mal
bleiben dass das der steuerzahler kostet
jede kriminelle karriere ja klar aber
soll jetzt stationen das zahlen die ich
das betrifft mich heute sind die fans
selber entscheiden ob sie mich ist eine
institution in indien aber nicht
was würden sie denn mit der in wien
machen
schwierig schwierig wahrscheinlich
jahrzehnte lang gesperrt und dann mit
rusal anders einer salbe logan bailly
versucht ja schon im film bruch
die schraube weiter anziehen
bis es lernt dieser logik folgte die
justiz lange im fall carlos jugendanwalt
darüber ist bei ihm schon sehr früh sehr
hart eingefahren
erfolglos
das war ein 11 jähriger sachse gesperrt
da seht ihr englisch nicht für möglich
halten vor allem zu tätigkeiten dass ich
das jedem auch er hätte ich jetzt zeit
sich nicht und das ist so zog sie meinte
nur wir sind ratlos
im allgemeinen herrscht indes keine
ratlosigkeit im jugendstrafvollzug klar
ist zum beispiel fehlverhalten muss
sanktioniert werden schnell und
konsequent aber die wissenschaft weiß
noch mehr noch viel mehr
die wirksamkeit von sanktionen gehört zu
den am besten erforschten feldern der
kriminologie was in der fachwelt
allgemein bekannt ist erstaunt den laien
stabiler kriminologische bestand von
empirischen erkannten ist wo es zeigt
dass weder straf noch schärfer bestraft
maßgeblich auf die
rückfallwahrscheinlichkeit einfluss hat
wenn große untersuchung genau gerade
amerikaner zum gespielt natürlich mit
todesstrafe droht
das halte mir ab aber das ist jetzt
wirklich richtig schlimm
überhaupt liegt
in den usa kommen auf 100000 einwohner
4,7 morde in der schweiz sind es nur 0,6
also fast acht mal weniger obwohl in der
schweiz viel mildere strafen drohen
und welcher besonders aber trotzdem sie
haben ganz massive repressive strafe
sehr lange intensiv es darf niemand
merkt wirklich in das amerikanisches
klang ist wirklich niemand und trotzdem
sind die faktor so uns wirklich so
unglaubliches prozent dass das
eigentlich wenn man genau analyst die
lage
das schien die - relativ kurz argument
dass mir nicht alles falsch machen
zu hause unter druck ist der ruf der
schweizer jugendstrafrecht es im ausland
ausgezeichnet
seit 2009 informiert russland seinen
jugendstrafvollzug in zusammenarbeit mit
schweizer experten roger de weck ist der
kopf der delegation erkennt der
schweizer system als langjährige
heimleiter aus dem effeff er reist
regelmäßig nach russland und wird hier
inzwischen als freundin von er kommt mit
netten worten und einer klaren botschaft
pädagogik damit ist sozial jugend nicht
das wort herr tv zeil boards konsequent
pädagogik das ist wichtig konsequent ihr
ziel mit perspektive verbunden ist mit
ausbildet mit perspektive für zukunft
das in jugendliche eine berufsausbildung
und nach hersteller und selbstbewusst es
ist einfach am start das ist wichtig und
aufbruch zieht das ist ein langer
prozess und das rotunda viel geld
valerie maximin kuh ist als stabschef
der russischen strafvollzugsbehörde
einer der starken männer
russland habe diverse systeme evaluiert
sagte er
auch das amerikanische am ende aber man
sich für den schweizer weg entschieden
die schweiz geht die komplexen probleme
mit denen wir es zu tun haben
differenziert und vernetzt an
verschiedene fachleute arbeiten eng
zusammen
das ist der richtige ansatz wenn man
erreichen will dass diese jugendlichen
später selbstständig leben können und
keine wiederholungstäter werden
eher nüchtern die rückfall zahlen und
blutige revolten haben in russland zu
einem grundlegenden umdenken im
jugendstrafvollzug gefüllt mit schweizer
hilfe sollen aus gefängnissen nun
erziehungsanstalten werden das fängt bei
baulichen maßnahmen an
aus riesigen schlafsälen werden vier
zimmer die schweizer experten lenken den
russischen focus nicht nur weg von der
reinen repression sondern auch weg vom
kollektiv hin zum einzelfall
erfasst werden auch ihre eigene oft nach
ihrer schicht sie da sind der jupiter
führt dass man mit ihm läuft warum bin
ich da was auch nicht gemacht
was sind mini zukunftsperspektive und
das haar in der großgruppe einer
differenzierten machen
der eingeschlagene weg ist teuer ein tag
hier kostet etwa gleich viel wie in
einer schweizer maßnahme mehr
annehmlichkeiten sind zentraler
bestandteil der reformen
intern wird aber bereits der vorwurf
laut die gefangenen würden zu sehr
verwöhnt natürlich müssen die
jugendlichen spüren dass sie ein
verbrechen begangen haben und hier eine
strafe verbüßen
aber tatsache ist dass viele aus sehr
schwierigen verhältnissen stammen
wenn wir sie erziehen und auf ein
normales leben vorbereiten wollen
dann erreichen wir das nicht indem wir
sie hier möglichst schlecht behandeln
täglich fußballspielen sinnbild für
einen paradigmenwechsel central soll
nicht mehr die anzahl jahre hinter
gittern sein sondern wie diese gestaltet
werden damit setzt russland um was
kriminologie und psychiatrie schon lange
wissen
das große bild ist eindeutig eine strafe
und abschreckung erhöhen bei
jugendlichen straftätern die
wahrscheinlichkeit für rückfälligkeit
und haben offensichtlich eine
schädigende wirkung
das belegen zürcher forscher die
zusammenfassungen von über 250 studien
ausgewertet haben
eine freiheitsstrafe
und wenn er nicht so gut ist machen mit
option natürlich weg mit dem unter der
voraussetzung dass sie wiederholt oder
unser land müsste sie nur gut aus sie
jederzeit irgendein floss nämlich
irgendwie um bis zu 50 prozent kann die
justiz die rückfallwahrscheinlichkeit
senken wenn sie therapeutisch richtig
interveniert auch das zeigen besagte
studien in der schweiz helfen
spezialisierte trias einrichtungen wie
das aha basel der jugend anwältin
passende einrichtungen zu finden
hier werden pädagogische abklärungen
gemacht gutachten erstellt und maßnahme
empfehlungen abgegeben
annett dance die pädagogische leiterin
sagt unser system habe vor allem zwei
potenzielle schwachpunkte dass alle
maßnahmen zwingend mit 22 enden ist und
dass sie auf kooperation ausgelegt sein
das nicht dass man keine probleme hat
und sich auch nicht wird unterstützen
los und biss neues ausprobieren dann
kann man kann die maßnahme umsetzen
jugendgerichte sprechen bei schweren
delikten meist einen freiheitsentzug und
eine maßnahme aus die er tief in 14 züge
werden aber nur vollzogen
falls die zeitlich unbefristeten
maßnahmen scheitern
das heißt wer in der maßnahme hat
wirklich genug reguliert macht diese
unmöglich und der freiheitsentzug ist
bald absolviert nein ich sage ich will
nie tante und probieren lösung finden
franziska chance bei carlos wurde
schließlich das vielzitierte sonder
setting eingerichtet damit er kooperiert
ein extrembeispiel für das dilemma in
das unser system jugendanwälte führen
kann wie weit sollen sie gehen um
rückfälle zu verhindern
ich würde es so sagen sie dann ihre
karriere nie gerechnet
so sei der umfang von der frühesten sind
das gab zweig sie
[Musik]
heime wie prell und die einweisenden
jugendanwälte müssen zusammen druck
aufbauen indem sie leuten wie i got by
kooperation vorteile anbieten mehr
freiheiten nicht kooperation führt zu
nachteilen mehr geschlossenheit
die meisten enden irgendwann ein und
gehen zb in die wöchentliche therapie
[Musik]
gronau sowie tank zu blöd wo möchte
was macht ihr denn sie was macht die
machen ja schön so schön und ich das
irgendwie profil genau so haben der
hatte fotoschule bild ich nur relativ
wenig druck sodass im relativ schwierig
werde zum audi materielle ziel auf
legalem weg zu verwirklichen
ja also es auch mehr realitätscheck
prozent auf jeden fall so aber sie
schützen das liegt ihnen und was nicht
und das war ganz schwierig zu
akzeptieren dass viele das studium nicht
in electric wissen frau das ist sicher
das thema yoga was ist was ich meine
fähigkeiten altmeister was kann ich
mache immer das abschätzen und um
konkrete und realistische vorstellung
die so lernen dass ich ehrliche arbeit
lohnt er und seine freunde haben dass
ein lieblingslied der neue bugatti und
so einen wird sich wohl keiner von ihnen
je mit ehrlicher arbeit leisten können
[Musik]
ich will nicht den für die normale
jugendliche ist es ist maßgebliches
kriterium ist geil ist zu machen
das geschäftliche stadt völlig
identische sekunde das kann die spieler
aber in erst richtig was sagt mini
kumpels ist das geil kann ich mich
wirklich prüfstein wir sind ganz andere
kriterien als das nützt das zeigt dass
solche relativ klar ab dem moment
wirklich hinter der schule sind ist er
wichtig steht maßgeblich einfluss faktor
die briefträger
[Musik]
auch im jugendheim erlenhof gibt es
schwierige fälle aber es gibt auch
vergleichsweise einfache jugendlich wie
gianluca b für die unser system
ausgelegt ist jugendliche bei denen die
justiz erfolgreich interveniert sind sie
suche vorzeigefahrer da ja schön sind
sie stolz auf sie so sehr liebe weg
vorbei
also von mir jetzt eine andere richtung
zeigt aber auch dass jetzt also alles
ganz anders gemacht auf anders machen
und bleibt nicht ständig sagen kann dann
sehr viel geholfen
die ist seit zwei jahren hier und
kooperiert auch ohne dicke mauern eine
betreute wg reicht weltmeister-duo haben
unser sport wo man für die wollen unsere
stock wohnen können der dusche an der
weser außerdem sind es geht dreht seine
runde und das teilung uns zu dritt
funktioniert das kommt ja doch das
reserveteam essen nur zu dritt und das
gemeinsame kochen über mobile gemeinsam
an sagt sietz nachlasse sie werden sich
so aktiv und rational der sowie der
wunsch schwiegersohn
also ich mir vorstelle dass sie wollten
er stimmt sie das wenn sie nur gibt so
was dass sie auch fähig sie sind los
wäre wenn jetzt so danke jetzt schon
erstklassig gemacht und ja also ich
würde es nicht normal mache sind sie
sich hier ganz konkret prozent konsum da
haben oder wo man unsere kleidung
waschen
warum einfach der schönste kohle und
dennis mal also kamera stand ist ein
fertiges schon dann muss man sie
überhaupt geht das schlüssellose ausgang
alkohol blaulicht so die kurzfassung
seiner geschichte stammt aus behüteten
elternhaus und hat immer wieder
zugeschlagen
wenn mit sog dankt uns auch gedanklich
hat ist anders seite mache aber da
moment wenn man nicht so wie du willst
was im gesetz ist etwas verschlafen das
jedoch in den worten mio zuschauer
anzieht ist ja einfach von kollegen oder
salbe vor der polizei erzählt abgeholt
da man dank mal wenn ich dran konsequenz
mein mann hatte gestanden die wenigsten
menschen jugendlichen sowieso nicht aber
die wenigsten dem einschlag überlege was
ich mache einfach sache und weil wenn
man mal überlegen denn überlegen das
verbot nichts machen dann überlegt man
sich nicht wie wird das bestraft wird
überlegt wie groß ist wahrscheinlich
dass wir verwirklicht werden wenn eine
harte strafe spielt überhaupt carola
wenn man sich dass ich das nicht
bestraft werden
das ist an sich ein polizei
diskussionstoff diskus
das heißt wenn man sich freiheit wird
müsste eigentlich jährlich etwa
kontrolle
ihr werdet nie polizistin aber und das
ist natürlich problem dass großstädte
lab ist genau was damals ausgerechnet in
deutschlands dass man wenn man 14
stunden wird ein polizist auf der straße
dass sie sechs polizisten und aussteller
an einer krank sind
vor gericht muss sich wasser als 16 wenn
sie 14 uhr ein auf der straße mit sich
sehr viele baustellen
das ist die doppelte strafe fazit nichts
gegen die repression aber am richtigen
ort und hoch dosiert bauhof enthaltungen
pc haben wollen wir was machen
man arbeite und für die vogue verfahrens
im zimmer und des tons praktisch dass
sie doch keine fernseher und schaut man
sich die gruppe setzte kann wo man all
die zusammensetzung bis besprachen die
wird in einer gruppentherapie mit seinen
taten konfrontiert zudem besuchte eine
einzeltherapie das bringt es nicht jedem
hilft zeit bis ich meine muster welt
gemeinsam auseinandersetzen und klare
das problem selber erkennen wenn man die
1000 abblockt und offen ist außerdem
hilft einmal nicht zusätzlich müsste ich
einen öffner also so lange diese
therapie machen bis ich mich mit noch
zwei wochen auseinandersetzung sieht
merkt euch muss das andere
[Musik]
es dröhnt selber nach jugendliche und
lehre dass sie für sich verantwortlich
wenn die welle das 7 zoll getragen und
es braucht man mal das jahrhundert haben
muss einfach wissen alles was mach ich
es wollte uns nicht zurück das buch zum
teil waren sie nicht lang aber es
verrückt jetzt hat es geschneit
dann kommt plötzlich
[Musik]
schön und gut aber was ist mit den
opfern der klub regelmäßig werden
unschuldige wehrlose menschen attackiert
sie werden verprügelt sie werden schwer
verletzt oder getötet
opfer seien häufig sie für sich allein
natürliches krasses missverhältnis somit
der uv different betriebe wird und dass
man für so vermacht also mit betrieb den
kratzbaum für die täter aber ende januar
für den betrieb der kasse ufer und auf
gesellschaft damit wieder täter wird
[Musik]
menschen wie ahmeti bleiben der ein
opfer ein leben lang dass er schon mit
20 21 jähriger probleme und unterstützt
mich allein gestellt sie nicht nur
kollegial kurve also einfach richtig
dreckig wie man mit der gestaltung der
umwelt und und man mit der zeit der
ungar das bessere leben nach der als vor
der tat und so verlangt
[Musik]
carlos hat anerkannt dass er ahmed 20000
franken genugtuung zahlen muss war
carlos hat kein geld
in solchen fällen kann die opferhilfe
einspringen diese bot 3000 franken ein
schlechter witz findet ahmeti der
bereits mit anfang 20 unter chronischen
rückenschmerzen leidet
[Musik]
dornbergs woche durch das training
nehmen die schmerzen ab aber der
eindruck dass recht und gerechtigkeit
nicht viel miteinander zu tun haben
bleibt jugendstrafrecht wird am seine
gedanken nur sehr mäßig recht der
orientierung auf quasi behandle ich wenn
man sofort sieht ist das in behandlung
oder prävention zukunftsorientierung und
das in fertigungsstraßen eines wichtig
denn bedeutet dass bis zu einer gewissen
grad dass man die vergangenheit sollen
die richtigkeit der muskel vor dem
boston wo passiert ich muss zurück
stellen
das ist richtig dass das führt oft nicht
so einfach ist aber und das ist struktur
dahinter gesellschaft sein wir sind
wichtig dass du wenn der mensch kommt zu
dir zurück also in das alte werk oder
also der mensch kommt die gesellschaft
zurück und mir waren die mehrstunden
sich vorstellen dass er das zukünftige
opfer ist es wichtig das vergangene
aber es ist natürlich schwierig ist kurz
das ist wichtig und war nur es eine lüge
und sage man das alles unter einen hut
bringen das kann man nicht nur seine
pistole
oder wenn man seitlich zukunft wichtiger
dann zahlt man mich auch die
vergangenheit und der vergangenheit
wichtig oder gerechtigkeit und sollte
man eventuell höheren risiken
[Musik]
noch die zweijährige lea außerdem auch
sehr spaßig und außer der arbeit und
metallwerkstätten herzens mit
was dann genau aus wie schweißen oder
aufschriften da doch nicht nur deutsch
auf das schloss
[Musik]
ausbildungen soll junge straftäter in
die gesellschaft zurückführen
in dem sie konkrete perspektiven
eröffnen ein zentraler punkt um
rückfälle zu verhindern
hier wird fachwissen vermittelt und mit
strukturierten tagesabläufen halt
gegeben
[Musik]
ein ic war ein gewalttäter betonung auf
war sagt er
kürzlich hatte die lehre als metallbauer
als einer der besten seines jahrgangs
abgeschlossen
du bist nur drei wochen haben wir leider
abschied von anderen fachleuten der ganz
positiv auffalle stich selber dass du
hier unterwegs auf dem weg in seine
kassen wieder mal ruft keine anrufe und
das soll bedeuten immer schön bei der
stange blieben tisch und darfst du die
hersteller hochspannung und für deinem
herren wofür einfach dass du das noch
als tabu war circa definition irgendwer
nochmals erleben hier leben möchte und
in der funktion einfach starten und wie
es von der person
es ist laut es dir es hat mir sehr viel
spaß machen ist das männliche
jugendliche ich halt einfach die
berufliche integration eines zentralen
die schweiz immer noch möglichkeit
braucht jeder irgendwo eines krieges vom
verhalten vor dem jugendhaus im
sozialverhalten möglich ist aber was
machen wir mit jugendlichen wie carlos
die mit 17 den schul stand eines
drittklässler haben und auch bei
vollbeschäftigung nicht vermittelbar
sind
jeder hat doch einfach notwendig machen
ja schön aber wenn der coach stand ist
unterstufe verhalten ist derart
schwierig das nur sein leben heißt also
das ist ja ohnehin unmöglich sie und
griechisch das immer wieder fitness
instruktor oder professioneller
kampfsportler waren in diesem fall
halbwegs realistische wenngleich
problematische perspektive
ein cross krachen ist ibooks nicht auf
das gute idee ja das war absolut
berechtigt die frage ich meine wenn der
vorschlag chronische schmerzstörung sie
sich schon und dann ist die zweigstelle
hallo ich verändere eigentlich genügt
also es ist ja nicht so dass sie dem
fall die muskeln waffel entscheidendes
sie sind in dir dich schon im gefängnis
entstanden
das problem ist verschiedenen musicals
und renault technik über mögliche ein
stoff verletzten hat so überlege kairo
ist natürlich auch gemacht dass ich das
weil die negativ konsequenzen oder die
positiv werden
außerdem besteht bei vox eröffnung im
ring und so schnell das sind witzige wo
man dann gemacht wo man kann sehr groß
und mit sicherheit die richtig oder
nicht
dann kam der sturm und machte alle
differenzierungen unmöglich und gröbers
vorgesetzte den bis dahin als kreativen
praktiker gelobt hatten brachten sich
sogleich in deckung
ich jedenfalls hätte einen solchen
vertrag nie unterschrieben
ebenfalls nicht mit diesen
kostenpositionen ich heute hier
kritiklosigkeit und fehlendes
fingerspitzengefühl
wie haben sie das erlebt die
zusammenarbeit mit ihrem direktor
vorgesetzte mit dem regierungsrat
wieso
das denkmal hat einige der frauen
verpasst
es ist es ihre theorie maßnahme ist
deutlich billiger als sehr schwierig
aber sie bringt ja und dann hat die
diskussion führen so wie mir sieht führt
auf alle härten und berechtigte frage
probieren
gegenargument bringen das ist leider
unterlag wird und sie sich im stechen
gefühlt für einen vorgesetzten
das kann man schon so sagen was ist das
für ein signal sie im ganzen festivals
wieder schaffen sie die pension gut wie
sie es ist schwierig sie glaubt sie
einige wurden ganz große gefahr erhöht
ist dass der druck von außen und innen
groß ist offen
gleichzeitig mancher oder mühe mehr
täglich junge menschen schätzen als
überlegen wir live dass einer so machen
wenn es anders machen und die verlegung
ich mache das wo man schief läuft nicht
auf mich wollt das ist heute ganze
zentrale überlegung unbedingt das ist
das wo am meisten chancen möglichkeit
über inhalte sondern mehr
was muss ich machen damit man schief
läuft ich nicht ist schutzwirkung
das ist freilich entwickeln
[Musik]
heimleiter wie pascal brenner die an der
front des jugendstrafe zugestehen
arbeiten in einem spannungsfeld das sich
zunehmend auflädt auf der einen seite
der gesetzliche auftrag nicht primär zu
strafen sondern zu erziehen
auf der anderen seite die mehrheit der
bevölkerung die mehr härte fordert
immer mehr heimisch fühlen meint die
breite öffentlichkeit mit jugendlicher
bzo das heißt dass sie sich kaputt geht
es entweder stadt und aus dem sommer
werden möglichst kostengünstig oder der
druck noch einmal zusammenzuführen nur
ich das einfach nicht so jugendlichen
kann ja das sind menschen menschen mit
geschichte geschichte wie sehr sich ein
können entwickler und wir sind den
vortritt möglichst mit der jugendliche
selber mit allen beteiligten eine lösung
zu finden
das kann man nicht von heute auf morgen
[Musik]
inzest fall brauchte es sechs jahre bis
hin brenner nun zum auslands gespräch
laden konnte
was wird der see sagt er hätte ihnen am
meisten kurve in der optik meister
unterstützung also bleibt oder ob sie
sind immer wieder zeit anteilen oder
kopf mit lange es geht
sie wuchs in einem gewalttätigen
elternhaus auf die gewalt die er dort
erfuhr gab auf der straße weiter selber
zuzuschlagen seit damals wie eine
erlösung gewesen sagte die behörden
durchbrachen diesen teufelskreis durch
eine platzierung im heim wo sich
zusehends stabilisiert
muss es einfach so oft wenn es
formulieren drogen vollgepumpt
aggressiven typen mit unkontrollierbarer
vermutlich wie eine bombe
sie trennt exportieren
[Musik]
eg hat sich ebenfalls stabilisiert er
arbeitet inzwischen im
landwirtschaftsbetrieb des jugendheims
bringen sein erster urlaub verlief
problemlos er steht unmittelbar vor dem
wechsel in die halboffene wohngruppe und
jetzt das gestern hat seine erste große
liebe mit ihm schluss gemacht per
telefon
was ist passiert mit ihrer rauen beine
nicht nachrichten büro hat mich einfach
als techniker oder braucht und was haben
sie denn gemacht aber ich muss verstärkt
warnt box wahrscheinlich nichts lebens
ab bis sie sich verletzt haben ein hoch
spezialisiertes team hat sich seit
nunmehr neun monaten mit g beschäftigt
und plötzlich sind alle fachleute macht
dies für den 17-jährigen bricht gerade
eine welt zusammen und nichts macht mehr
sinn
ich bin ich groß drüber frist das hat
mich ihnen das probieren verarbeiten und
wieder machen
[Musik]
am nächsten tag ist gs zimmer leer
er ist auf der flucht
die direktorin des jugendheims brel
zeigt was die als erstes erwartet wenn
er gefasst wird fünf tage scharf arrest
im sogenannten bunker
[Musik]
sexy dessous
dass ich jetzt hier die spazierhof
schließlich für disziplinarrecht sei
also der heizung strom wasser oder sport
hier oft gut das ist der sturm hat
frische luft
[Musik]
nach zwei wochen ist gs flucht vorbei
seine erworbenen freiheiten hatte wieder
verloren
alles halb so wild findet er
nachtrag welt immer die gleichen mann
verhaftet wird das jetzt ein punkt tag
gedruckt sie dass alle klassischen im
bunker hocken und werden haben derzeit
überlegt wie man weitermachen was man
für aktionär hat vier wochen nach diesen
aufnahmen muss gpl verlassen
er kreierte so massiv dass er untragbar
wurde die jugendanwaltschaft muss einmal
mehr eine neue lösung suchen
es geht es geht fall wo sie nie glauben
verstoßen das sind ganz wenig iv und
verhängnisvoll wird eine weniger
radikale umkehr zu machen
wenn dann hätte man künstliche bereich
vielen anderen termine für erfolg
wichtig
[Musik]
sie wohnt schon lange nicht mehr im
erlenhof erarbeitet nur noch dort das
heim hat den westteil basel eine
einzimmerwohnung dauer gemietet so
sollen jugendliche möglichst realistisch
auf ein selbstständiges leben
vorbereitet werden
wieso hans ist geschafft
der wille der eigene quellen zählt ist
wenn deine der bierschwemme wenn man
kann will 16
dann bringt es ganze sache nicht
wie weit dürfen recht und gerechtigkeit
auseinander sein diese frage stellt sich
gesellschaften grundsätzlich beantwortet
werden muss sie aber im einzelfall
dann wird es kompliziert
[Musik]